the 10 commandments maintain an
extraordinary hold on our imaginations
even though many of them sound in the
context of our own times really rather
peculiar with all those injunctions not
to cover to neighbor's livestock or to
make sure one doesn't carve images of
godlike figures in the rocks the
Commandments were responses to the
specific needs of a small nomadic
community wandering the Sinai Peninsula
with goat and sheep around 1200 BC our
needs have predictably changed a bit
since then but a place for rules remains
because we're still horribly prone to
violence cruelty and self-righteousness
and need regularly to be reminded of how
to live peacefully and well with
ourselves and our neighbors what would
it be like to try to update the
commandments for our own times here is a
go if a good person is at all times
highly aware of their flaws and
committed to becoming a better version
of themselves they're not insulted if
people point out their need for
evolution even when they do this rather
clumsily the good person believes in an
ongoing need for moral and psychological
education the good person knows that
everyone is deeply damaged and a little
mad
starting with of course themselves their
unfried 'end by their own strangeness
and are committed to informing those
around them of it in very good time and
apologizing retrospectively when they
fail to do so they understand that part
of their duty is to have a ready answer
to the legitimate question and how are
you crazy the good person is loyal in
relationships not because they think
that their lover is perfect but because
they know that everyone is pretty
imperfect and rather hard to live with a
close range they accept the only people
we can ever think of as normal or easy
at people we don't yet know very well
the good person knows that it's
impossible to be wholly understood by
anyone and accepts that things are going
well if one's very lonely in only around
half of the key areas of one's life the
good person tries hard never to assume
that other people should know what
they're thinking of or want without them
having told them very clearly and kindly
they try to resist sulking behavior that
stems from an incensed belief that
others should know why we're upset
without us having told them and they're
committed to teaching others about the
contents of their minds the good person
looks at people who are behaving badly
as if they might be small children that
is with patience charity and an active
search for mitigating circumstances
though our society's stress the insult
have been treated as younger than one is
the good person knows it's the greatest
privilege for anyone to look beyond the
apparently strong yet nasty adult to the
worried anxious and probably really
rather nice child within confronted with
a piece of stupidity or evil which they
would never be good toward the good
person doesn't fall into
self-righteousness they swiftly remember
all the many stupid and evil things they
have at other points over different
things being guilty of they don't lose
sight of how much they overall stand in
need of the charity and forgiveness of
others
the good person is committed to
searching for the funny side of people
who might appear merely desperately
irritating they look at others like
characters in a comedy rather than a
tragedy they know that the greatest
achievement is to be able to move from
seeing someone as an idiot to
considering them as that most privileged
of beings a lovable idiot the good
person is a firm believer in restraint
and in not immediately saying certain
things that are on their minds they hold
the beam fully oneself entails a level
of melodrama and rage that one should
spare any human one cares about the good
person knows that the best protection
against impatience and paranoia is a
little gently worn pessimism they budget
for disappointment far ahead of time
they don't cry constantly only because
they've understood that the whole of
existence is in many ways worthy of
tears their constant awareness of the
possibility of death and catastrophe
makes them especially appreciative of
small things that happen to go well they
relish flowers balmy skies and so-called
boring days when everyone manages to go
to bed relatively content and at peace
you